yeah like like again because i'm running
a small team my opportunity cost of
someone failing
not because of them but the data is
actually high
um
so i don't have like a bulletproof way
to sort of prioritize projects i mean
generally speaking we try to look at
revenue potential
is the data completely new
or is it something that is new and
is it new and can be linked to something
we already have
generally if you get something that's
sort of
independent from the rest of the
database you're like your value
proposition is going to be
much harder
but if it's something that is related to
some of the companies we cover today and
they have other measures
then there's a higher
success chances
um but yeah it's happened to me where
you basically work on something for like
six months plus and then you end up with
like well i guess it didn't work you
know
um
it's unfortunate but i mean
it kind of comes back to the business
side because you kind of try to
whoever's adding this project you try to
do your best just have them explain
in very simple terms
what they want out of it right and and
that's where i kind of use that
sometimes when things kind of fall apart
they're not very well defined then it's
like well
we really didn't know
so we tried and it took a while because
of these complexities and at least we
found out that why we failed
so that's not really an opportunity
anymore so that way you kind of dance a
bit around the
issue right
you